how's it going back my name is Pierre
and welcome back to the game that
everyone just kidding me hey you guys
are masochist I didn't even show the
title that's not good for anyone
oh and someone sent me a map of this
side I don't have it I don't have the
map anymore I'm kind of regretful
god damn it but I know it's kind of like
a circle and in the center there's all
this stuff and the forest is the circle
I think let me just get that in my head
and maybe today we will find all the
eight pieces Isis I see someone there
come on don't make it seem possible he's
already out there and also the more you
know about slender the marred you likely
to abduct your at penis I don't know
what I don't know what his deal is I
mean I don't ever did anything to him
alright don't look
alright ah [ __ ]
how will I not be able to luck eversince
I'm not saying I'm really only
responsible but everything I play this
game it's been [ __ ] exploding on the
interwebs I mean I seen it on so many
places which is not good but splendor is
upset about it he doesn't want to be
famous you just want to get out the lady
if I'm stopping him from getting all the
ladies that means I can never find
anything on that thing is there really
nothing on this one Oh actually holy
[ __ ] there it father I keep thinking
that he's out there good problem Slendy
no not a problem we got two pages pretty
elite defying me say so myself and
there's not a car I don't think we're
what a [ __ ] was that is he here
uhh
okay yes no no no no no no nono nono
nono nono nono nono nono nono nono nono
nono no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no doing pretty
[ __ ] good supply no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no ah he's
not behind means that behind me he's not
behind me he's not be enemies that
behind me not bailing
I'll give the start but gorgeous I like
that
oh come on what does he want from me why
did they ever do it here there no note
in here oh there it is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
always watches no eyes
I was doing so well so well huh hello
again I was pretty well I'd say a ten
out of ten toe breakers I [ __ ]
launched my feet in there hello
they had now it's good it's all about
fun when you play horror games Knifer
open up computer ready for a new scare
never always afraid no matter when I
think I'll be okay he [ __ ] Silla
barge into my face Smurfs don't wanna
change page just good sound man good
sang I said I guess their notes are
random cuz it's not on this [ __ ] tree
which is no bueno but for the bed
alright no no no no no no I felt like
that song they'd actually work a little
bit no no no no no
no no no no nope nope
- Betty [ __ ] no no [ __ ] you no I was
not fair either you [ __ ] teleporter
when I was picked up that sugar no come
no better no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no he's out there isn't
[ __ ] you I bet you're watching me
yeah the fogger you [ __ ] creep up on
me when I'm reading notes
what the [ __ ] that scared me I thought I
saw something that it wasn't there
really there I think that's probably
what scariest thing of this is yeah
don't see me don't see me don't zoom in
don't zoom in he doesn't like when you
zoom it's no bueno he's acting me now
I'm gonna I'm not gonna look back this
time I know he's behind me I don't look
back what I heard the noise he's out
there I heard a static
there is something so [ __ ] creepy
about this game it's so simple and so
stupid okay it's not stupid don't get me
but it's simple really simple it's just
a [ __ ] drum sorry man
no no no where do you go where do you go
where do you go where do you go pedigree
what let's go
all right nothing bad can happen when
you're singing a happy song my happy
song a happy song everybody is happy
Shan lalala everybody
oh I never seen deep if I have you seen
these Sunday you wanna go check it out
with me ah oh no there's no thing
this is [ __ ] grab it and run the [ __ ]
out of [ __ ] I don't know what I just
said but this is a drag-tastic I bet
he's an ass dick [ __ ] did he go I don't
want to know don't look or it takes you
I have four notes [ __ ] you're not gonna
stop me from collecting your papers oh
you're embarrassed because of your
artwork it's on YouTube [ __ ] it's on
YouTube
dddddd what's going on
alright this area is really horrible
because I don't know where the note
spawns and it's really big and he could
be around any [ __ ] corner and I don't
like corners
I don't like oh there it is
help me no no no no no no no he's angry
what the hell is he doing staring at the
gasoline we're just gonna kinda go in
house my house brick repair and the male
of a penis
all right so dark it's so like it's a
dark and so like it's a dark dark dark
as a dog dog dog it's a dark
it's a [ __ ] dark I like to beat and
Mark I'd be oh mama
maybe she hurting me what the [ __ ] am i
doing there's got to be no gin here it
just has to be a note hockey some
Spanish dude says he's offended by my
bad Spanish
I'm fine I just need three more
I didn't eat free wine it has come to
this again
[ __ ] I didn't I just know this will not
end well
I just [ __ ] know it after that I'm a
blob Rahab Lincoln was a good president
he had a beard and that's how much
Chinese Jamie's I can't believe it's
still scaring me so much it's it's crazy
it's crazy I really didn't good I think
the first time I played it it scared me
so much because I did it really there no
[ __ ] about it and now that I know more
[ __ ] it usually makes it less scary but
now it's still [ __ ] terrifying but
it's funny how it's still so simple and
it can still freak people out so much I
really like that about horror games have
something so simple can have such a
[ __ ] impact on you it's crazy
and then I I I definitely suggest trying
out the game yourself cuz you're not if
you're feeling up for it because I do
decrease the volume settings and
brighten up the footage and it does it
does make a lot of difference I think it
leaves but anyway like favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe bridge day and I'll
see you next episode of are ever I'll
make salesman breath don't stop shaking
somebody's humping me right
what
am i raping someone or am I getting
raped and up get it